gus we're home
you get me some chewy
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
are we on the same page right now yes
i'll turn the new spider verse
[Music]
no oh young venue oh littier
santa barbara's only pop-up cat
restaurant
sure of course a catfish
oh nice do your parents know you're
doing this what
how old do you think i am 41. 41. like
the girl from orphan
congrats business is booming um we don't
open for another 15 minutes oh so the
cats aren't the customers
who the hell are you guys i'm sean
spencer this is my partner ding dong
ditch nope
clotto dirt mm-hmm big papa pump warmer
lemon and lemon aluminum lie
hello how did either of you reach
adulthood
don't worry you will too as long as you
keep taking your vitamins okay i am not
a child
what do you want isn't it obvious we
want love and companionship and the end
of the ivory trade
but most importantly we want to know
what you think you're doing opening a
cafeteria in our office
well i am a legit entrepreneur and i
rented this space
and it's mine for the next 19 days oh
those are for cats
[Music]
i see okay i'm going to be honest with
you guys i am in a real dickens of a
stare down with the health department so
i'm going to need you to get to the
point
all right here's the nutshell i'm a
psychic
he is a sympathetic pooper we're back to
retrieve dozens of detectiving tools
that we've stashed in the walls
ceiling and air ducts and that may
require punching a hole or five well
you're gonna need to take that up with a
landlord
and he's not gonna like it back there
thank you old woman
or young child whichever you may be
what do you want hi looking for approval
to destroy your drywall and possibly
remove your air conditioner no
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off
sir if you would just allow me to
explain the magnitude
yeah wait hold on back up we can't help
but be disturbed by how low the register
of your voice is you're clearly putting
on some sort of billow tomber
this is not a tomber it just got lower
just showing boys so you admit it's a
voice yeah who are you doing tom waits
kathleen turner harvey fierstein
dietrich bader
sean get in here dad
how in the hell could you afford to buy
the psych office
i didn't buy anything you neglected to
tell your landlord that you were moving
what i simply picked up the payments and
started subletting to every hipster
pop-up coming into town
i'm literally rolling in disposable
income
tax-free this seems illegal why are you
bothering my tenants we may have left
behind a few items when we moved you
left behind the slow cooker with a
three-pound roast in it
you nearly this is us the entire block
this is us dad why are you watching that
show they have the same show on abc but
newer
what do you want uh this is embarrassing
but i think i'm allergic to these cats
not my problem what look dad this is a
lassie mystery the stakes are possibly
life and death which means i need my
night vision goggles
and my collection of mustaches in order
to snoop around undetected
will you please help us
velassi
of course you're using the voice again
you